tonight the politics of drugs they're at
the heart of a contentious Senate race
in West Virginia three Republicans vying
for the GOP nomination all have their
own ideas how to combat the growing
crisis of opioid abuse where's mine at
Peter Doocy shows us tonight from
Charleston West Virginia the candidates
have spent time in either court Congress
or a Correctional Facility
now Republicans competing in West
Virginia's Senate primary are fighting
about who is best positioned to fight
the opioid epidemic we've been tackling
the problem about as aggressively as any
office can Patrick Morrissey the state's
Attorney General is taking credit for a
court victory that just inspired a
freshly proposed DEA rule which could
cut down on opioid production part of
the reason why we sued the DEA is that
we found out that the national drug
quota system had utterly failed our
citizen but in Washington Congress cuts
the checks for opioid prevention and
treatment and the only candidate
currently serving there is congressman
Evan Jenkins I have served on the
Appropriations Committee the six billion
dollars working with the White House
that we've just approved is a
significant positive step in the right
direction Jenkins who helped start a
Recovery Center for infants born to
drug-addicted mothers is also trying to
convince voters that the Attorney
General Morrissey has ties to the
industry partly blamed for the state's
drug problem
if a person has deep roots and
relationships from all of his lobbying
experience with big pharma I don't know
how we can trust him
Morrissey doesn't think Jenkins can
credibly make that claim I think Evan
Jenkins is a hypocrite and Evan Jenkins
for many years in his career took
massive quantities of money from the
pharmaceutical industry when he was the
head of the State Medical Association
now a fresh set of eyes on the epidemic
comes from the contender fresh out of
prison
former Colbert and Don Blankenship who
served a year on misdemeanor charges
tied to the Upper Big Branch mine
disaster the wall is very important
ending the sanctuary cities is important
drug testing public officials
particularly teachers and judges and
prosecutors is important his ideas
mirror the president's and Blankenship
believes Jenkins and Morrissey each had
to address opioids when elected and blew
it I think that both of them are greatly
responsible for the epidemic because
they haven't done enough it's rare for
there to be a competitive Republican
primary in this state so this is the
most detailed that Republicans running
for statewide office have gotten in
debates about opioids in years and
there's urgency because the CDC says
that West Virginia has the highest rate
of deaths from drug overdoses anywhere
Brett Peter Doocy live in Charleston
Peter thank you